i love this guy i love everything about
him i love his
uh his mind i love his coaching i love
just his personality and his friendship
uh most of all because we sit next to
each other on the first round of the nfl
draft
on nfl network uh he is the head coach
of stanford football david shaw back
here on the show how are you coach
i'm doing great rich good to talk to you
what yeah what number year is this for
you or is this your 10th time doing this
with us
are you at number 10 yet or at least it
has to be somewhere around there
this is you know well i keep track it's
my 17th year doing the nfl draft on nfl
network right chris is that what it is
uh you're 17.
i've been i've been saying that once a
day uh david just to get myself psyched
up you know what i'm saying three four
there is an eye in richard eisen so you
mean cleveland doesn't get you psyched
up enough
that does yes it does well we let's just
hope they might not remember some of the
uh
some of your uh evaluation of baker
mayfield as a first overall pick
but i'm kind no you are you are no but
that's that's the
best part about you you dovetail our
philosophy of
of just of giving an evaluation that
there's always positives there
might be some negatives there might be a
problem with the fit you don't say it's
an
it's an impossibility that somebody uh
can't succeed so
it's a perfect fit for you and our and
our coverage so let's get into
your evaluation of the quarterbacks
david shaw
that's available in this year's nfl
draft if you don't mind what do you got
for me on your board
where do you want to start let's start
with i guess trevor lawrence is he
number one on your board or you're a
zack wilson guy or
what what where are you on that david
shaw you know i've talked to daniel
bunch about this and i've watched the
film over and over again
and those two guys are so intriguing i
do think there's kind of a line
after those two guys um trevor just the
ceiling is
off the charts um it's not just
athleticism the guy is fast
he's tall he's got strong arms an
accurate passer
um and as a coach you always i always
think about the offensive line
and wherever this guy goes jacksonville
uh
they're gonna love him right this guy
doesn't just run this guy tries to run
people over he's tough he's a fighter
um this is the franchise guy and i'm
excited about him when you put on zach
wilson
maybe you see some things that you like
maybe a little bit better than trevor
i mean the film as as in its totality
might be a little bit better but the
size and speed and athleticism and arm
strength and the accuracy of trevor
lawrence
makes him the guy so give me the the the
parts because you you went a little bit
uh higher register which we notice here
on the rich eisen show that sometimes
you got to go there to
to to uh couch your comments a little
bit
because that is something that uh we
don't hear a lot of
that zach wilson could be better at this
than trevor lawrence
what is zach wilson better at that you
think than trevor lawrence as a prospect
entering the draft
uh there's one thing that i absolutely
love about watching quarterbacks
and i think it's a direct trans
transition from college to the nfl
and that is the combination of
quick footwork and quick release
and accuracy and that's what zach wilson
has
he is quick he is explosive he is
accurate
um that ability to see something open
and get the ball out of your hands
really quickly because we all know the
windows in the nfl
they open but they close very very
quickly this guy's got the ability
uh to to see see number one and get to
number two and as soon as he sees number
two that ball starts to come out fast
and i think it's
uh a quicker than anybody else in the
draft this year
um and i i get excited when i see that
um but to me that doesn't
that it's not enough to overtake um the
the phenom that clemson so let me ask
you this david shaw
two red flags if you will or flags that
could be
somewhat tinted red for zach wilson
um are one the level of competition
that that he has faced coming out of byu
and two that he was not a core captain
what do you say about both of those
things that get thrown in the direction
of zach wilson
during these evaluation times you know i
think all of those things
i call them accents right you always
start with the film you watch the film
and then you collect all the accents
okay all the stories that you hear the
people that you talk to
i think pro day is an accent i think the
combines an accent
interviews are the accents and then
after you get all those accents
then you go back and watch the film
again before the draft um
to see okay how do i combine all of
these things together to give me an
evaluation
and he's got a live arm he's got live
legs
uh it reminds you a little bit of baker
uh coming out
um but for me i think he was a little
bit better taking care of the ball
um then bakery threw the ball in very
safe places i thought baker took a lot
of chances and i think his first two
years in the nfl kind of showed that
and this past year the interceptions go
down and guess what
the they get to the playoffs um and this
guy i think he takes care of the ball
really well
there's still gonna there's a little bit
of a frenetic face to him too that may
need to calm down a little bit
um i watched the pro day and it was
outstanding
and about five of those throws you hope
that
he never has to make those throws in nfl
games right because they're extremely
dangerous and coaches get worried about
their jobs when you're making a bunch of
those throws
but the fact he's got the ability to
make them and he's got a history of
taking care of the football
makes you feel good about it so what
about those two specific accents
i put on the table uh about the level of
competition is something that makes an
evaluation to the next step
difficult and uh that he was not a core
captain for byu
that might be an issue for somebody
that's you're choosing number two
overall as the jets for a leader
of a franchise
a lot of times you don't know the the
politics and history
um of of why someone is or isn't chosen
a captain
um sometimes it's not for anything that
they did other than maybe
him being a little bit young uh and you
know a little
young and energetic to say it nicely
when he was when he was young at byu
um and uh so if you can find those
stories if there is something that you
find then maybe
you have pause but for
who he's been what you can never forget
either about college kids you know i'm
with these guys
all the time there's a maturity that
happens
usually somewhere between sophomore and
senior year sometimes sophomore junior
year
where their guys are more composed
they're more mature
and i think that's what's really
happening you watch the guy he's very
composed he's very confident
um guys the guys like playing with them
it's not like he's an outlier and we've
kind of seen some of those before
not to bring up any names where that
guy's a great player but
he has no friends on the team um that's
not the case here
um i think uh i think uh the the jets
fans are going to be excited about him
i'm not saying he's broadway joe uh but
at the same time he's gonna bring some
juice
and energy to that franchise david shaw
stanford university head football coach
getting set to hang with me and charles
davis our second hour guest daniel
jeremiah and the cast of thousands on
nfl network's draft coverage
later on this month right here on the
rich eisen show so
again uh another reason why you're so
terrific uh
for an nfl draft uh is you spent many
years in the nfl and so
also in rooms evaluation rooms draft
rooms and whatnot
is it possible the 49ers made that big
of a jump from 12 to 3 spending
that much draft capital to go from 12 to
3
for a quarterback that they still are
evaluating and grinding tape on
that they did not know the exact name of
the quarterback that's not named wilson
or lawrence that they're willing to
spend all that
to do you know and i have no knowledge
of how they got there or why they got
there right um but you can kind of look
at it from the outside and saying hey
we've got a quarterback that we really
like
who has not completed a season in two
years there are
multiple first-round draft pick
quarterbacks in this draft and they're
probably going to go early
so hey maybe it's let's just get up high
so make sure we get one
because we need to get one and now let's
decide which one
um i know there's you know people saying
all kinds of things they could take a
tight end they could take a tackle
whomever
they're probably going to take one of
those quarterbacks and it's not like
they're desperate like they have to have
a quarterback
if jimmy g stays healthy this is still a
have a really good chance to be a
playoff team it's now
can we insure ourselves against jimmy's
health history
and get the future uh in this draft so i
understand the the
the process of getting there and
realizing you know there are
potential five first-round draft pick
quarterbacks and none of them might get
out of the top ten
so you have to get up there if you want
to get one so the general sense of
things too
coach shaw is that uh mac jones is gonna
be the choice because he's the one that
fits the shanahan
system the best what do you say about
that
uh axiom that we're hearing pretty much
every day now
what do you think of that this is this
is like for for quarterbacks especially
more than any other position
this is always the argument um that
comes up
so often where are you choosing the
quarterback that best
fits you are you just choosing the best
prospect
and sometimes one is better sometimes
the others better
and and i can't tell you which one is is
which at times
but for all of us that have seen kyle
shanahan um
he's got a great offensive mind many
have called him one of the best in the
league which i think he is
um and if he and john lynch feel like
this is the best
fit then that's the guy with no
hesitation
right you've heard uh maybe they go for
trey lance since we're talking about a
guy that maybe is going to sit for a
year and has a ridiculously high ceiling
we talk about level of competition and i
mean jump in a couple of rungs to get up
to the nfl level we think this guy's got
the ability maybe that's good maybe it's
justin fields
right the play action game the boot game
who knows the guy that guy
also takes care of the ball doesn't turn
the ball over so
where it could be mack jones who some
people have labeled a system quarterback
hey the guy throws the ball accurately
you know that's what she needs
quick decision maker he throws the ball
accurately um he put guys around him
and it's proven now that he can make
some plays so knowing shanahan system
which one
fits and is that the one that you have
evaluated the highest out of those group
of three quarterbacks david shaw
yeah i i honestly have bounced back and
forth between
justin fields and mack jones for those
two reasons um
i can see mack jones because i i can
picture the offense
at alabama and just put him in san
francisco
and say he's run a lot of the same
concepts he's going to walk in knowing
what to do
um he's going to have a learning curve
like anybody else making this big jump
but he's not going to have to make it
you know in six months he's gonna have
to make it hopefully in 18 months or
longer
um and i can see that uh easily i don't
know
um how i would pull the trigger because
it's not on me right now
uh but i could also be swayed by justin
fields because of that athleticism
because of that 4-4
if he does get in trouble he can take
off and run
he also has a strong arm he also takes
care of the football
um so you can make an argument to take
the guy that you can picture right now
fits perfectly or the guy that gives you
that added dimension as a runner
which is so vital right now in the nfl
what is your evaluation coach david shaw
of justin fields there was a huge to do
last week
um when dan orlovsky of espn put it out
there that his work ethic
has been questioned what is your
evaluation on all of that about
justin fields david shaw well i
i don't know dan um that never works
that never goes over well for somebody
who's not in the building
who maybe talks to one person that says
something who knows
um i i i would never cross that
threshold because it's something i
didn't see myself
um as an nfl evaluator to really look at
the skill set
the the the the potential detriments
that i see on film or what other guys
have seen on film also
is for what i talked about zach wilson
does extremely well seen and getting out
justin every once in a while has a
tendency to be flat-footed and
it's not the same level anticipation
which yes you can improve on it's not
something that he'll never get
um but that that quick decision making
that quick
release um sometimes you don't see that
you see it periodically you don't see it
as often um as far as work ethic
hey the guy's a great player he's a
great athlete he's a leader
he's got toughness he's got all those
things that you're looking for
um and to say that he's been that
successful
over two years at ohio state and and
doesn't work hard
um i'd have a tough time believing that
david shaw stanford university my
colleague
uh for the first night of the nfl draft
on nfl network right here on the rich
eisen show i've asked
many evaluators all right we've named
the five right lance and
and fields and jones and wilson and
lawrence give me somebody outside of
that five that's got some ability
that can make some hay certainly in the
draft and then
be that person that's outside of the the
radar screen
and the name that comes back uh on mass
is davis mills
coach shaw i'll give you the floor on uh
the stanford quarterback
what about him yes and for me i think
he's
in the mix with with these five when you
watch the film and you put on what he
does well
you're gonna see sides you're gonna see
athleticism you're gonna see arm
strength you're gonna see accuracy
you're gonna see a guy that can handle
protections he can handle the running
game you see him changing plays
um all the guys that have talked to him
have been have been
pleasantly surprised uh to say it nicely
about his his football acumen
the guy knows the game and understands
it so
for me once again like i said earlier
you go back to the film
what the film tells me this is an nfl
ready quarterback
um that in my my opinion rivals
uh especially those those next three
after the top two guys he's right in the
mix in my opinion
when you watch the film um he's gone
from sleeper
to kind of not sleeper to oh my gosh
should we get up or
should we move up should we trade back
should we do something to make sure that
we get this guy
because he might be an nfl starter and i
believe the more film you watch
the more you get uh convinced that this
guy not only can play
but he's gonna walk into the nfl ready
to play so do you think like end of
first round i know look
people might accuse you of saying you're
trying to push your guy up into the
first round but i
you know the bears are sitting there
they took a big yolo swing at
russell wilson and did not connect we
all know
there are you know there's new england
sitting right there in the middle of the
first round
uh we're already hearing that they could
trade up for fields if he if he drops or
even
all all the way up to atlanta if if if
free agency belichick shows up on draft
night you know
like what what where what would be a
good fit do you think
for for mills um on draft night
yeah that's that's the question um i've
heard everything from from late one to
early two
um and here's here's what i say if if
davis mills has a full 12 games and not
the six that we played this year
um he put actually i still say he played
four and a half
um because of a erroneous coded test
um if he has a full 12 games
i think we're talking about him in the
mix with that five um
top 15. um i think if he came back for
another year
then i think he's probably the best
quarterback in america now you're
talking about a top five top 10 picks so
now
if you do project them the way that most
guys i've talked to
say okay if this guy was going to be is
going to be the number one pick next
year
and if he had a full 12 games this year
his top 15 pick
why not take him in that in that late
mid late first round early second round
knowing that this could be my guy for
the next decade
so yeah right when you're talking about
that
late first round it's more than worth it
to take a guy
that who's once again the film
evaluation not just not the hype not the
stats the film evaluation
shows all the things you're looking for
and i usually start with a little
checklist of things i'm looking for at
each position
and you know you actually you actually
check off everything that you're looking
for
when you watch this guy play and so last
one for you this is the question we
might
even be asking uh in our pre-draft show
thursday night we we may still be
wondering the answer to the
loan remaining from what it seems
assuming mac jones is a 49er
question uh as to what the falcons are
going to do with matt ryan having two
more years very expensive years
potentially uh unseverable two
expensive years left on his contract
also
kyle pitts sitting out there at four or
lance or field sitting out there for or
somebody knocking on their door
to go and get one of those quarterbacks
what would you david shaw
counsel the falcons to do at fourth
overall
right now so i i call myself an nsl
evaluator right now but i'm also a
football coach
yep so for me whenever anybody says
developmental and first round
i start to cringe right because that
means usually somebody else is going to
end up coaching this guy
so for me i'm looking at i'm looking at
the top tied in
uh prospect to come out in a while i
don't know if i could pass up that guy
to have that that quarterback and those
two receivers for at least a year um
and that tight end that to me i would it
would be too hard for me to pass it up
now the bigger offices
in the building may tell me to pass it
up right but for me
i'm like i can't think about year two
year three i'm thinking about what we're
doing right now give me that tight end
and let's go play you love kyle pitts
huh
uh it's the the phrase mismatch
nightmare gets overused
this guy is a mismatch nightmare he can
play receiver he can play tight end um
he blocks well enough right you don't
have to be a dominating blocker he
blocks it well enough
but when this guy runs there a couple of
linebackers that could probably run with
them in the nfl and there
there are no safeties to have the size
to battle this guy especially down in
the red zone area
um this guy is all the good tight ends
that we've seen over the last decade
kind of rolled into one um i have a
tough time passing are you saying he's
complex
is that what you're saying david shaw
there's no cops for him
uh kyle pets no no nobody likes my comp
that i
that i say i i say i say jimmy graham
um because jimmy graham dominated the
nfl for about four years
because he was too long too fast too
explosive and played with drew brees
now you give matt ryan this guy um this
guy's gonna average
i hate to put things on but this guy's
gonna average 15 17
18 yards to catch um who's going to run
with this guy on the scene with julio
outside and right now don't forget
ridley too right
and yeah and and really could have a
career year right because every
every every defense coordinator is going
to say okay take care of julio and the
freak tight end
and our third corner you get to go cover
ridley no wonder we might
kill it no wonder the dallas cowboys are
are you know
i i you know if i'm jerry jones i'm
i'm thinking do i tell stephen and
everyone in the room or
let's get them all on the same page to
to get up from 10 and stick him
with dak zeke gallup cd lamb
and amari cooper and say dan quinn fix
the defense and then we'll draft
otherwise to fix the defense in this
draft and go to work i mean why wouldn't
they do something like that right
yeah usually i'm one of those guys that
tempers other people's enthusiasm about
a prospect
but this guy probably more than anybody
in the draft is going to change the
outlook of your offense
he's going to change the outlook of your
offense he's going to make life easier
for the receivers
if he does nothing else but release and
run straight down the middle of the
field
um this guy can change what you do on
the offense
i will see you in ohio sir and on uh on
some uh some zooms
beforehand to get ready for it i i truly
cherish the times that we get to sit
next to each other i look forward to
seeing you
see you soon rich right back at you
that's coach david shaw of stanford part
of nfl networks draft coverage
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here